how you doing man I like seeing white
dudes in my show that's good you're
straight that's what's up man
nothing against gay Jew is I just see a
lot in New York you know I mean you
would throw back a nice [ __ ] straight
white male it's rough for y'all out here
about to put you at a different fountain
and everything this is getting bad for
you guys oh this is your girl beautiful
man are you also a white half sellout
white girl go get that [ __ ] Aryan man
you met his parents
no yeah that's right keeper keeper oval
secret for low why nothing there's a
little bit of racism I'll tell you what
you got a 90s outfit that reminded me
the 90s was the best decade of racism
it was [ __ ] perfect man it was just
like look we can be friends we don't
have to pretend white people aren't
crackers that's it was a fun time he
would make jokes about each other
remember that guy god it was great and
now just [ __ ] you gotta like meet a
quota with a half something girlfriend
I'm not saying you're not great miss you
probably are
it's just I'm sure when you said I'm
half Nicaraguan or whatever he was like
yes yes that much less racist that much
less racist he probably looked up the
GDP of your country and if it was mad
low he was like [ __ ] it like a fantasy
dating league they're collecting points
based on how oppressed the girl is how
poor the country is you get like 60
bonus points if they don't got toilets
over there